for the Austrian based designers to be
asked estulin Florian pushman of white
elephant design lab the experimentation
and exploration of materials and their
excitability by external influences is
an important resource of inspiration in
our work we often set the preconditions
for what will happen and we just let
materials intact next to quite
traditional tactics in product design
our work also deals with a more holistic
approach of home finding they are
fascinated by natural phenomena and the
potential of the qualities of material
having studied the larvae mature and how
advanced the smooth and shiny surface it
had I thought what if we tried to think
of a way to shape and form it as the two
designers did more and more research it
became clear that they had to go to Big
Island of Hawaii the islands Kilauea
volcano is the most active volcano on
earth and surface flows of the smooth
before hyped lava occur quite frequently
during their four-week stay on Big
Island in February 2009 long and
exhausting hikes were needed to reach
the area of active surface flows a
rugged terrain sheer endless oceans have
solidified abrasive lava rock I thought
there's that massive amount of energy
noise it's a very calm and peaceful
situation they knew it was necessary to
bring special protective gear in order
to be able to get really close to the
hot lava and to work with it they
obtained protective suits that are used
in the steel industry
discovering the reality of the actual
setting the view on the whole project
and their approach was changed
fundamentally this new ethical framework
we apply change the way we work
completely we even cut back some of the
projects because we felt they were not
really appropriate to that specific
sacred area we found
the project zero 2009 was one of the
major works carried out by Tobias Kessel
and Florian Bushman on Big Island of
Hawaii volcanic activities have been
going on since billions of years on this
planet placing this symbol of long-term
thinking in this context seemed to be
just the right thing the O in front of
the 2009 refers to the long now
foundation and indicates in a quite
strong powerful way that there's a lot
more time to spend and to plan for than
just the next decade
this place represents the past present
and future it's about destruction and
creation at the same time working on
liquid rock is maybe the most
fundamental thing for a designer I think
you won't get any closer to the matter
you